matt damon is the last white man left in
los angeles that is what i got from this
movie
elysium one of the most looked forward
to movies of the summer wow i watched
this movie on imax this movie kicked so
much [ __ ] ass i
i would [ __ ] this movie you guys if you
haven't seen it you're missing out just
turn off the review and go watch it if
you have seen it then stick around for
the points i'm about to make the story
[ __ ] loved it did you see all the
smith that came out of my mouth that is
how much i loved it it's just a a world
that has so much going on in it with
political themes and family themes and
even some religious stuff if you really
read into it rich people poor people
there's not that many blacks in this
movie too that's what i noticed
a lot of mexicans but the story is so
grand so it's like the genre is science
fiction fantasy and wow does it deliver
on those genres the directing of this is
so good neil blimp or whatever his name
is neil blumkamper this dude [ __ ]
excellent job i loved it because he can
do like everything every kind of genre
when there's he really
strong human dramatic moments it's
perfect he really knows how to direct
his actors and he could do like the the
science fiction elements he could do the
action the action is so good the
cinematography the editing all of it
just so [ __ ] good like i kind of
don't want to go into it because there's
no point all you got to do is take my
[ __ ] word for it the tone is cool you
know what else is fantastic matt [ __ ]
damon i'm [ __ ] matt damon look at
this guy even bald and suffering with
radiation disease he is still
[ __ ] sexy just from looking at those
beautiful blue eyes you can feel a back
story and then he does action and it's
like wow this guy he's so nice but he's
tough at the same time he can be a total
badass and they're saying like oh he
goes all born again no he doesn't this
guy born can kick anyone's ass born
don't lose this guy gets in situations
where he gets his ass handed to him
sometimes why because he's [ __ ] human
he's an underdog he had a rough life
[ __ ] guy you know he all they wanted
to do was go to elysium let's go to
elysium
but no no no it cost too much money so
he stole cars he tried making some money
he really he really tried he went out
there and everything and [ __ ] just
didn't pan out well then he got a job
his boss was a douche
[ __ ] he gets radiation he's got
five days to go to elysium he has to get
to elysium everything is about going to
elysium
everything
and shredder copley or whatever the
[ __ ] guy's name is charlton copley
yeah that's it uh he he is uh scary as
[ __ ] in this movie there there's a
moment towards the end where a bunch of
crazy [ __ ] is going on that we should be
terrified of but you know what happens
to be the scariest part
this [ __ ] guy
no just knowing he's going after the
main character ruthless the scary thing
is he's so three dimensional very
expressive performance but at the same
time he doesn't feel like he's chewing
up the scenery necessarily that feels
very authentic you know i didn't really
like jodie foster her performance did
not feel sincere her accent i did not
know what the [ __ ] was going on there it
was very distracting i felt like she was
trying to you know chew up the scenery
twirl a little mustache in there play
with her penis that she secretly has
it's very distracting performance she'd
actually pull me out of the film this
awesome film and academy award winner
jody foster would pull me out of the
movie there's a dog barking
this is a raw show and the action whoa
it's so cool some of the coolest science
fiction action shots i've ever seen and
what's really cool about the action 2 is
there's drama behind it you can actually
feel emotion going on here it's [ __ ]
intense matt damon manny
no
the poster fell
we have to go to elysium that's the
thing about elysium anything is possible
and all the effects are [ __ ]
beautiful orgasmic semen filling this
film is it's like dark it's gritty it's
kind of ugly at times and at the same
time it's all beautiful to look at from
the world on earth to elysium it's just
so great and the score the score is
fantastic perfect choice of music per
theme and yes there are some
similarities to district nine but
honestly just take this movie on its own
merits and i'm telling you it's
fantastic it's one of those rare summer
blockbusters that encompasses
more story than trying to just be there
for the thrills then the thrills are
there they're way more amplified because
the story is so strong everything about
this is perfect except for [ __ ] jodie
foster let me get straight to the point
here all in all i gotta say elysium got
it super right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for elysium why don't you go
ahead scroll that comment box below and
tell me what is your favorite physical
thing about matt damon and yes it could
be his penis and if you want to go ahead
and follow me on twitter you can click
this link right here i'll follow you
back
so i don't have too many friends on
there yet and if you want to see more
in-depth review of elysium go ahead and
check out my show called reasons to see
that i do with my buddy jerry and we
have special guests on the show aaron
and yeah there's two white people two
that is double the amount of white
people that will be around in the year
2154 and if you want to get updated
every time one of my reviews or videos
is out
go ahead and subscribe to my channel by
clicking on this button by my penis
that's right when the world's coming to
an end
no one's going to be going to elysium
you're gonna be looking for this bad boy